President Trump will meet with vice
president Mike Pence today at his New
Jersey golf club hence and other top
officials added their own comments
yesterday to the president's fire and
fury warning it turns out the specific
language mr. Trump used Tuesday was not
planned major Garrett is near the trump
National Golf Club major good morning
good morning let's just set the stage it
was the one and only encounter president
Trump had with White House reporters
during his working vacation his senior
advisors knew North Korea would be the
question and were prepared for the
president's tough language what they
were not prepared for was his
improvisational sabre-rattling a
presidential ultimatum the kind that can
change history best not make anymore
threats to the United States they will
be met with fire and fury like the world
has never seen before President Trump
delivered that statement he was in
regular contact with chief of staff John
Kelly and his national security team was
aware of the tone the words however were
the president's own they were clear the
president was going to respond to North
Korea's threats following the sanctions
with a strong message White House press
secretary Sarah Sanders said in a
statement the words were somewhat
familiar used before during the campaign
we have a movement the likes of which
this world has never seen before
you propel to victory a grassroots
movement the likes of which the world
frankly has never seen before Secretary
of State Rex Tillerson tried to reassure
edgy Americans and allies during a
refueling stop in Guam not Americans
sleep well at night have no concerns
about this particular rhetoric over the
last few days later State Department
spokeswoman Heather Nauert insisted the
administration was unified whether it's
the White House the State Department the
Department of Defense we are speaking
with one voice North Korea is not the
only national security challenge
President Trump faces Afghanistan is
another and in both instances the
National Security Adviser HR McMaster
and the defense secretary general mattis
are urging a more aggressive military
posture while chief strategist Steve
Bannon is urging caution and trying to
find a way to avoid conflict with the
president's rhetoric this week Margaret
it's clear he's focused on North Korea
and forward leaning on the military side
of that equation major thank you